every Thanksgiving
Americans eat close to 736 million
pounds of turkey that's the weight of
almost a thousand 747s at takeoff so how
does a turkey make it to your plate it
all starts with an act of love
usually artificial insemination as soon
as a day later you've got an egg that
travels to a hatchery that becomes a
baby turkey that shipped off to a barn
often in Minnesota Jones channel if that
weren't hellish enough after about 18
weeks and now mature turkey gets sent to
a processing plant int processing is
kind of a euphemism the turkey gets
unloaded in the dark with its homies and
is stunned through electrocution or
gasps next the throat slitting machine
then scalding picking and more gross
stuff time for packaging only the
prettiest turkeys are packaged whole
then the turkeys shipped off to a
grocery store where you buy it take it
home and roast it mmm at this point we'd
like to ask white meat or dark before
you can even begin stuffing your faces
with stuffing